NARRATOR: In the rugged
cliffs of Southwest Montana,
Jake is on a high-speed chase.
[howls]
Come on!
NARRATOR: To keep pace
with his youngest hound.
Now I got to go ahead
and catch up with Marlene.
She's trailing that calf.
NARRATOR: Who's
broken from the pack
to track and tree a 200-pound
mountain lion all on her own--
for a second time.
Pretty cool to
see, but she probably
shouldn't be
running a big column
like this by herself anyways.
Son of a bitch.
It looks like Marlene has got
him locked down right now.
And that's a pretty
badass sight to see.
[barking]
Wow.
That's a big calf, big calf.
NARRATOR: Marlene split from the
pack a mile down the mountain.
Come on, Marlene.
Good girl, Marlene.
NARRATOR: To pick
up their trail,
Jake relies on his
emergency tech.
I've just got Henry
and Lefty located
a couple of hundred yards away.
But got a hell of an
obstacle course ahead of me.
Looks like the dogs are trailing
just over top of this ridge.
I've got to pick my
way up through here.
This is a nasty, nasty cliff.
It's not going to be fun,
but it's the only way
to get up and through here.
So let's go, Marlene.
Get up there, baby girl.
Good girl.
NARRATOR: The monster cliff
faces a near vertical climb.
These rocks are slick as hell.
NARRATOR: On a coating
of treacherous black ice.
It's real important that I try
to stay on these dry patches.
If you look down
underneath the snow here,
there's a lot of ice.
Every bit of that
is slick as [bleep]..
And one false move
here, and it's
going to be a real bad day.
Come on, Marlene.
This is a route I've taken
in the past by myself,
but today is my first
experience trying
to lead a puppy through it.
Come here.
A little further.
Get over here.
Come here.
Woo!
Close call, baby girl.
NARRATOR: In a race to catch up
with the rest of his dog pack--
The conditions
right now aren't
real ideal for taking this
route, but we can't let up now.
NARRATOR: But sitting
between him and his hounds--
I've got to Henry and Lefty
up just over the ridge there.
NARRATOR: Is a 300-foot vertical
wall of ice and solid rock.
Good girl.
All right.
NARRATOR: And the only
way through is up.
Let's go, Marlene.
Come on.
Here.
Good girl.
Come here, big girl.
Come here.
I'll lift you up
through this part.
Good girl.
Get up there.
Let's go, Marlene.
One last little pull.
Climb up there, baby girl.
Good girl.
All right.
Now that I'm over
the ridge here,
I need to get these dogs
caught up right now.
I can hear them just a
couple hundred yards away.
Yeah, that's a big cat track.
Both dogs are in it, and they're
treeing just ahead of me.
I'm going to make my way
up here real quietly.
I'm making my way
up to these dogs.
I can hear them
treeing pretty hard.
All right.
Here's the captain.
You can see its butt
facing towards us.
Good boy.
NARRATOR: Altogether, Jake's
team treed two cats three times
in just a matter of hours.
Looks like Lefty and
Henry are doing their job.
They got that cat up there.
Good boy, Lefty.
Good boys!
Good dogs!
NARRATOR: A hard
day's work and a sign
that the valley's predators are
showing no signs of surrender.
Now that we got this cat
far enough off the ranch,
it's time to go ahead
and pull the dogs
and make our way
back to the truck.
On to the next one.
I feel like today
was highly successful.
I've pushed away two
cats instead of one.
But tomorrow is another day, so
we'll get right back after it.